I mean I look forward to discussing our
new partnership to establish the dynamic
ventilator reserve as you know hospitals
throughout the country currently have
more than 60,000 unused ventilators it's
you probably never had so many have you
or what do you think
are you building up are you going down
are you going in the right direction but
we're building thousands of them right
now we're grateful that through this
initiative your hospitals are committing
to lend unused surplus ventilators to
other hospitals if they have an
immediate need and you've been doing
that we appreciate it FEMA and HHS will
support this initiative by guaranteeing
that in the unlikely event a lending
hospital needs before if there is a big
lending need more ventilators we will
make sure that we have them we will make
sure that you get them and we're a great
backup for you we are building literally
thousands of ventilators right now
as you know and they're starting to come
in other countries have also been asking
us for ventilators I don't know if
you've been having that situation but
we're being asked by other guy just got
off the phone with the president of
France and we are being asked about
ventilators from everybody everybody
when the virus struck our nation
governors raised fears that people who
needed ventilators would not get the
ventilators my administration has used
the defense production act and it's
really had a big impact on companies and
companies wanting to get them done and
get them done quickly we're preparing
ventilator capacity for any and all
scenarios initiatives like the dynamic
ventilator reserve will help us to
achieve that goal we need ventilators
but now we're pretty well stocked we
really needed them we took over a
country which was I've been saying to a
lot of people they don't like to write
it but the cupboards were bare in many
ways including ventilators in addition
under the defense production Act the
United States will produce or acquire
more than 32,000 ventilators by the end
of May and over listen to this 1/100
50,000 ventilators by the end of the
year so we're going to have more
ventilators by the end of year we've
ever even thought possible and we'll be
helping out some of the states but we'll
be helping out other countries too which
I think we have on a humane basis we
have an obligation to do we're getting
tremendous calls from Italy in France
and Spain and a lot of other countries
beyond that by the end of the week HHS
will finish distributing the first 30
billion dollars in direct payments to
more than 300 thousand hospitals and
healthcare providers if you don't need
it please let me know we won't make the
check available to you I think you
people have been having a hard time from
what I'm understanding you having a hard
time and I understand that very well all
facilities that accept Medicare payments
are receiving funding based on the
amount of Medicare fee-for-service
payments that you received in 2019 if
that makes sense is that is that what
you're looking at right soon HHS will
distribute additional funds from the
remaining 70 billion dollars provided in
the cares Act a big deal to get that
passed a significant amount of this
money will go to the hospitals and
hotspots while a portion of it will
reimburse hospitals for the cost of
treating uninsured patients and for the
coronavirus so I think that's pretty
much what we've been talking about and
what you're looking at so now I think
what we'll do is I'd like to maybe in
front of the media you can go around the
table quickly just introduce yourself
and your association your hospital or
whatever it is whoever you're
representing and say a couple of words
if you'd like please we'll start with
you Thank You mr. president
Sam Hayes and CEO of HCA health care we
have 185 hospitals across the country
and we're proud to be a partner with the
federal government we think that's the
only way fundamentally to solve this
crisis and we're proud to be a part of
it thank you thank you very much
I'm mackelmore and chief Community
Health Officer for Intermountain
Healthcare Intermountain is based in
Salt Lake City Utah and not-for-profit
integrated system we're testing about
65% of those getting tested in our
communities right now and the surge is
fairly small in our community and we
believe that this is relative to other
places and not yet and we know that this
is going to be a dynamic situation and
so we appreciate the opportunity to
collaborate with the federal government
and with our colleagues hospitals across
the country because we think flexibility
is really important to being able to be
using we're using a few different tests
we have some bio fire tests yes yes the
antibody tests are using that too we're
just exploring antibody tests right now
I want to be careful about how we deploy
that and because we don't have many
people who've been exposed to the
disease in our communities it might not
be time yet for antibody testing how
many cases do you have would you say in
your community we have about 2400 in the
state of Utah has relatively very small
relatively small and and gives us
concern about what can happen if we
relax but we are being diligent good job
you've done a great job thank you very
much president I'm David Hill I'm the
president CEO
LifePoint health we own and operate 88
hospitals brought out through 29 states
in smaller communities which I know our
community is very important to you we
applaud the efforts of your
administration on dispersing the 30
billion dollars in funds quickly our ask
is that we continue to deploy the
remaining 70 billion dollars rural
hospitals are very important part of the
infrastructure of this country and also
treating the uninsured and the Medicaid
population as well so thank you for what
you've done we have not seen a
significant surge at this point either
although our caregivers have done a
fantastic job of preparing and we are
all over the country 29 different states
think about the middle part of the
country we don't have awesome
we have no have any hospitals on the
west coast in California also in the
Northeast but virtually every state in
between or where we don't have the big
that's right we only have a couple of
hundred Kovac patients today in our
hospitals our biggest risk I believe our
nursing homes and so protecting our
nursing homes making sure that our
nursing homes are stable and we're very
careful that's great great job thank you
very much yes mr. president Joe and
peachy Kay president CEO of Ascension I
represent under 65,000 associates in
communities across the country we have a
hundred of the hospitals in 20 states
we're proud to be part of this
partnership appreciate your leadership
mr. president and I like to thank you
and vice president pence for everything
you're doing
I appreciate Association and thank you
mr. president for having us in and I
want you to know that we appreciate the
leadership of you and your team in
putting together this dynamic reserved
for the ventilators
you know you've already heard that
there's a little bit of an uneven impact
in terms of the disease in the battle
that we're fighting and this will allow
us to provide an opportunity to flex so
that we can get the equipment to the
right places at the right time for those
that are really struggling and this is
an innovative approach that we're
committed to the hospital systems around
this table have stepped up to the plate
to make commitments and you have our
commitment at the American Hospital
Association that we will work with the
rest of our field to make additional
commitments and make this a success
we're also building a very high quality
ventilator because you have to make a
decision and I was told it makes a big
difference the level of quality of a
ventilator what is it what what is the
difference do you find it makes a big
difference they're obviously more
expensive more detailed
harder to build but I hear they are more
effective quite a bit is that do you all
consider that to be correct that's great
a ventilator is not a ventilator there
are a lot of different versions of
things that have different capabilities
only the one that they say is you know
we're trying to go at a standard that's
very high and you think that's worth it
we think this project makes it very well
worth it absolutely it makes a
difference thank you good job mr.
president Warner Thomas I'm the CEO of
akshar health in New Orleans with the
largest not-for-profit health system in
Louisiana
we've been caring for about 60 to 65% of
the Cova patients in New Orleans over a
third of them for the entire state so we
have seen an escalation over the past
few weeks although we're seeing some
flattening of that curve now and we're
excited to be part of this program I
want to thank you and your
administration and certainly our
governor who was helpful in getting
ventilators to us when we were going
through the process in the state and
we've been working very well with you
governor and with your two senators - it
made a huge difference for our patients
and and we're excited to be part of this
program so we could help other
communities that may be in need of
ventilators as well we also built a lot
of hospitals and hospital beds in
particular and we just cut back on the
final because you didn't need them which
was great you didn't need them so you're
seeing the flattening right now we are
seeing some flattening in the curb and
and certainly we're hopeful with that
continues you know over the next couple
of weeks and and the shelter in place
has had a has had a major impact in our
inner city great you know say hello mr.
president my name is fritz Francois I
serve as the chief medical officer at
NYU Langone health Kansas since its
regards and as you know we've been taken
care of patients on Lee in Manhattan but
also our forward is in Brooklyn as well
as long I land
and we've been in the heart of it and
and do what I really thank you for not
only supporting NYU but also the New
York hospitals we've been in the awesome
and similarly we actually seeing a bit
of a flattening and we're continuing and
committed to taking care of these
patients so once again thank you for all
your efforts I spoke to Ken yesterday
will will take care of all the situation
you people have really done a fantastic
job during this crisis please yeah mr.
president my name is Tommy Holloway I'm
the president and CEO of Cleveland
Clinic what we have a strong presence
obvious in our home state of Ohio but
also large presence in Florida southeast
close already felt a big one right
fortunately in Ohio the measures by our
governor who instituted very early and
we have really not had a surge in the
number of patients and the curve has
been flat for almost two weeks on our
entire system we employ 60,000
caregivers we with having only hundred
and seventy patients in our entire
system and the number has been the
number has been stable and what I would
also like to echo my colleagues here
that we're thankful for for the
invitation but I also want to assure
that we all collaborate among among each
other and lend a helping hand to those
who are well that's good and you do have
a great governor Mike has done a great
job and we appreciate it very much
so we're going to talk for a couple of
minutes and thank you all very much me